RESTRICTION, BUT THAT IS
DEFINITELY A GOOD SIGN FOR
SECURING THE BORDER AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED.
AND NOW, ONTO THE BORDER OF
INSANITY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE REACTION TO LAST NIGHT'S
SHOW FROM DEL RIO BORDER SECTOR
WAS SO OVERWHELMING THAT WE
COULDN'T LET IT GO.
NOW, WE BROUGHT YOU VIDEO YOU
HAD NOT SEEN BEFORE.
ALONG THE RIO GRANDE RIVER AT
THE NATURAL BURIAL -- BARRIER IN
THE MEXICO AND UNITED STATES, WE
SELL IMMIGRANTS ILLEGAL IMMIGRAT
SELL IMMIGRANTS ILLEGAL IMMIGRAS
JUMPING INTO THE RIVER FROM THE
MEXICO SIDE WITH FULL KNOWLEDGE
THAT NEARBY BORDER PATROL WOULD
JUMP IN AND RESCUE THEM.
>> THEY ARE GETTING READY TO
CROSS.
SO WHAT WILL YOU DO HERE?
>> HE'S IN THE WATER AND THE
BABY, HE'S GOT THE DEVICE ON.
THIS IS TERRIFYING.
A MAN SEPARATED, NOW YOU HAVE A
MAN SEPARATED FROM HIS BABY.
THE BABY IS CRYING ON THE OTHER
BOAT, AND BORDER PATROL IS LEFT
TO FISH HIM OUT OF THE RIVER.
WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME, IT IS A
DAILY STRUGGLE THESE GUYS HAVE,
BUT YOU CAN'T LEAVE AN INFANT IN
THE WATER STRUGGLING.
YOU CANNOT LEAVE BABIES IN THE
WATER THE WATER.
>> Laura: IT WAS TERRIFYING
BUT A FERRY SERVICE IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE BORDER PATROL HAS
BECOME.
NOW, THE LEGALS MAY BE INDIGENT
AND ONLY WHAT THEY CAN FIT IN A
GROCERY BAG, BUT THEY ARE
EXTREMELY WELL-INFORMED OF THE
LOOPHOLES AND OBSERVED
ENFORCEMENT RESTRICTIONS.
AND NOW, THEY ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE LOOPHOLES
WITH THE HELP OF THE CARTELS WHO
COME I GET THIS ARE PAID
HANDSOMELY BY THE ILLEGALS TO
HELP TRANSPORT THEM ACROSS
MEXICO AND RIGHT INTO THE HANDS
OF OUR BORDER PATROL.
NOW, HERE YOU SEE PEOPLE
CHEERING ON THE SHORELINE AFTER
THIS MAN IS PULLED ONTO THE
BOAT.
>> WHO IS THAT KID?
HE'S GOT A LITTLE KID.
AMIGOS.
>> YEAH COM AMIGOS.
>> Laura: I SPOKE WITH THE
MIGRANTS AND THEY COME AS I SAID
WITH LITTLE TO NOTHING AND ALONG
WITH THEIR CHILDREN WHO ARE
INNOCENT PONDS AND ALL OF THIS.
AND THE SADNESS AND THE FEAR IN
THEIR EYES COME I WILL NOT
FORGET.
BUT EVERYONE I SPOKE TO,
EVERYONE ALREADY HAS A PLACE IN
THE UNITED STATES TO GO.
>> [SPEAKING NATIVE LANGUAGE]
>> Laura: NOT JUST MARYLAND.
[SPEAKING NATIVE LANGUAGE]
>> Laura: WELL, I TOLD THAT
PARTICULAR MIGRANT, WE HAD A
LITTLE MOMENT OF LEVITY.
BUT THE POLITICIANS HAVE BEEN IN
TOWN PLANNING THIS FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
THEY ARE LYING TO YOU.
THIS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT JUST A BORDER STATE
PROBLEM.
ONE OF THE MORE ILLUMINATING
MOMENTS FROM YESTERDAY WAS THE
BORDER PATROL PROCESSING CENTER.
NOW, THEY DIDN'T LET US BRING
CAMERAS INTO THE AREA WHERE
ACTUALLY PROCESSING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FOR PRIVACY AND OTHER
CONCERN, BUT THEY ARE TAKING TO
THIS PROCESSING CENTER AFTER
PICKED UP IN THE RIO GRANDE.
INSIDE, THEY ARE SEPARATED INTO
CATEGORIES.
FAMILY UNITS, SINGLE ADULT
MALES, AND UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
NOW, THE FAMILIES I SPOKE WITH
TOLD ME THEY PAID THE CARTEL UP
TO $12,000 FOR PASSAGE.
BUT GUESS WHAT, THE MONEY IN
MOST CASES CAME FROM RELATIVES
OR FRIENDS ALREADY IN THE U.S.
IT GETS BETTER.
MOST OF THEM ARE ILLEGALS TOO.
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
OUR SYSTEM IS SO SCREWED UP THAT
IT PERMITS ILLEGALS LIVING HERE
NOW TO FINANCE THE TRIPS OF
OTHER ILLEGALS TO WANT TO COME
AND JOIN THEM.
OH, AND IT GETS WORSE.
>> WE HAVE FOLKS WHO COME IN AND
LITERALLY WITHIN 45 MINUTES,
THEY ARE IN A DELIVERY ROOM.
THAT WAS JUST A WEEK AGO.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND,
DELIVERING CHILDREN?
>> DELIVERING CHILDREN.
WE WILL APPREHEND THEM THEY WILL
BE EIGHT OR NINE MONTHS PREGNANT
AND THEY WILL BE IN LABOR AND WE
MAKE THE ARREST HIM BY THE TIME
WE GET TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
THEY ARE DELIVERING 30 TO
45 MINUTES.
>> Laura: GUESS WHO PICKS UP
THE COST OF THE HOSPITAL?
WE ALL DO.
TAXPAYERS IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE SUBSIDIZING THE ENORMOUS
COST OF HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEIR BIRTH ONES HERE.
NOW, I FOUND OUT TODAY IN 2018
ALONE, THE HEALTH SYSTEM IN
TEXAS THE LARGEST HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER IN THE LONE STAR STATE
REPORTED ALMOST HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES DUE TO UNPAID
MEDICAL BILLS.
THEY BASICALLY HAD TO WRITE IT
ALL OFF.
OF COURSE, SINCE THEY DON'T GET
PAID AND THEY ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED, BY THE WAY, TO ASK
PATIENTS ABOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS, ULTIMATELY THE COST IS
EVENTUALLY PASSED ON TO, WELL,
YOU GUESSED IT COME AMERICANS.
SO I ASK YOU, HOW IS ANY OF THIS
ACCEPTABLE?
WE HAVE U.S. VETS WHO STILL
CAN'T GET THE TIMELY TREATMENT
THEY NEED YET ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE ALLOWED TO USE EMERGENCY
ROOMS AS THEIR PRIMARY CARE
CENTERS FREE OF CHARGE.
IT IS OBSCENE, AND IT IS UNFAIR.
BUT YOU STILL THINK IT'S AN
EMERGENCY, RIGHT?
WELL, TONIGHT WE LEARN FROM THE
SOURCES AND RIO GRANDE VALLEY
SECTOR THAT THEY ARE BEING
COMPLETELY OVERRUN BY
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND ASYLUM SEEKERS.
OVER THE PAST WEEK AND THIS
STUNNED ME, 10,000 ILLEGAL
ALIENS WERE APPREHENDED BY
BORDER PATROL.
THOSE ARE THE ONES APPREHENDED.
AND THAT MADE IT ONE OF THE
HIGHEST WEEKLY TOTALS EVER SEEN
IN THE HISTORY OF THE SECTOR.
NEW NUMBERS FOR THE MONTH
OF APRIL ARE COMING OUT TOMORRO
TOMORROW.
AND SOURCES ARE TELLING US THAT
THEY COULD BE THE HIGHEST ON
RECORD.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS A COMPLETE
AND TOTAL TRAVESTY.
WE SPENT TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN DEFENDING
OTHER PEOPLE'S BORDERS.
AND WE HAVE ALLOWED OUR OWN
BORDERS TO JUST BECOME
MEANINGLESS.
ANY POLITICIAN WHO SAYS THIS